Ruby Freeman invoked the Bible after a
federal jury ordered Rudy Giuliani to
pay her and her daughter $148 million
for ruining their good name understand
that the devil is a liar he is defeated
and no weapon formed against you shall
prosper Freeman and her daughter Shane
Moss were elections workers in Georgia
during the 2020 presidential election
they Giuliani who was former president
Donald Trump's personal lawyer for
defamation this after he repeatedly
accused them of stuffing ballot boxes so
that Joe Biden could win it's an
accusation that forced Moss to quit her
job and subjected both women to years of
harassment and death threats from Trump
supporters our greatest wish is that no
one no election worker or voter or
School Board member or any anyone else
ever experiences anything like what we
went through Giuliani is already facing
trial in Georgia for allegedly
conspiring to interfere with the 2020
vote he is suggesting he will appeal the
verdict in Freeman and Moss's lawsuit
the comments they received I had nothing
to do with those comments are abominable
they're
deplorable no uh defense to it but I
receive comments like that every day the
odds of Freeman and Moss getting any
money from juliani are slim he's
considering filing for bankruptcy but
this mother and daughter knowing the
legal system took their case seriously
is what they call a big step toward
Justice Rosalyn Jordan Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer